all right it's Thursday baby so take
your tits off and throw them down the
street player this ain't time to be
breastfeeding one another we got work to
do
this past weekend
[Music]
hear that
[Applause]
[Music]
that's Jessie Lucero with that dirty
barbaric beat right there as Jessie
Lucero here on on Thursday January 4th I
just I got that in my inbox I want to
thank Jessie Lucero Jessie also played
the Auld Lang Syne from a New Year's
episode last weekend on Monday and and I
forgot to mention that Jessie did that
and Jessie could be a man or a woman
I believe that Jessie is a man but
that's me you know jumping new uh
jumping a crotch Cluj ins if you will
because I don't know you don't really
know you know I'm from an area where
they had a lot of people had names that
were it could be anything a lot of
people named after whether stormy stormy
hail dusty you know Dusty's not really a
weather but it's just more of like a
dirt condition
you know skimpy that's just really like
some of this cheap but uh but yeah I
grew up in that in that belt where they
had a lot of names a lot of people name
different things you know ro Dolph oh
they had a boy bust named Rudolph oh
they used to call him Dolphy and in kids
honestly used to beat him up a lot we
had people that had his boy name taught
by Us T ot and I've talked about him
before and he was you know he had a
little bit of the affliction kind of he
was one of God's favorites really you
know he you know the law he was half
angel half person you know had a hit of
that ISM and he used to he he would have
to stand her a blanket all the time he's
afraid to be outside of a blanket and so
taught taught had a easy name he was you
know granted an easy name so be easy for
him the spell you know hard to forget
taught t OT same thing backward forward
that's taught but that's Jesse loose
Sarah one more time
and this is that music if you're like a
little maybe you feel like a gay guy
getting chased by like a barbarian you
know
[Music]
but then the gay guy morphs into like a
19 like a 1990s metal rocker unicorn
with long hair and just [ __ ] attacks
the attacks the Barbarian
[Music]
and then they end up banging probably
and moving to a sanctuary city you know
good to be here with you guys welcome to
this past Thursday man I'm fired up
I just I'm going to tell you right out
of the gate that I have some upcoming
dates January 5th that's coming up ASAP
I'll be insanity in Santa Clarita on
Main Street at comedy mashup you can
google that and find those tickets 11th
through the 14th I'll be at the Brea
improv of January January 18th through
20th the new comedy club in Jacksonville
Florida February 16th through 18th La
Jolla California February 22nd through
the 24th Indio California fantasy
Springs casino and April 6 and 7th in
Tampa at Rock Brothers brewing oh good
to be here with you guys you know that's
how I'm feeling today I'm feeling I'm
feeling you know I'm feeling good we did
a little bit of yoga yesterday and I
like yoga man I like yoga until the
teacher the the teacher in ours is like
his really acrobatic homoerotic
gentleman and I don't he might be gay
might not be gay we might all be gay you
know I'm saying a special hit a
lightning hits the earth and it might
shake everybody's cells up a little and
next thing you know you out there blow
in the neighbor for powdered milk you
know the Dickie Dickie dust bowl there's
only a couple of you know lightning
strikes away we don't know what the
future holds but I know that I know that
this gentleman was seemed you know was
being homoerotic in there and and we
were in there in the yoga studio and he
you know it's a good class until the end
of the class is basically just him doing
tricks and it's like all this stuff that
you can't do and he's stretching and
he's got his you know he's got his
[ __ ] wrapped around his shoulders and
he's just you know he's wearing he you
know he's wearing his earlobes as
[ __ ] you know as uh he's got his
earlobes tied around each one of his
nuts and it's just you know he's in
these poses that you can't duplicate
he's at another level
and that's when I don't like it because
then it's just about him it's like at
that point he's just you know he's
tricked us all in a stretch and for 40
minutes so that he can have a crowd to
be around him so that's you know that's
when it's a little wild for me but but I
did that I felt a little bit better you
know I hit it hit in a a meeting last
night you know I needed that I needed
that hit and I'll probably go to one
I'll go to one tomorrow morning I might
go again tonight cuz you know I'm out
there I'm out there and those staying
dry streets right now I want to get to a
call that's gonna be our first is a
special episode because this is the
first live call that we've ever done I'm
thankful to Cory he just came on board
to help us out and he's like he's like a
little bit of that he got that um that
Wizard of Oz and him a little bit you
know he's out there in the in these
electric streets he know he knows what's
going on with electricity and how to
manage it and you know DiDio digital
video management you know he's like he's
like a you know he's like a peeping tom
but he's not doing the work he's making
these cameras do the work so he's like a
second he's like an overseer of these
little electric peep and timers that we
got out here from Cannon and Panasonic
and and thank you to the patreon errs
for helping us get a new camera and get
things rockin and get things rolling but
we got our first call and this is a
gentleman that called in on the Monday
episode he called in there's a part in
one of my comedy and my comedy special
on Netflix where I talk about shooting
up a Denny's I'm gonna play that for you
right now
[ __ ] Denny's Brook [ __ ] Denny's man I
wish people quit shooting up movie
theaters and shoot up a [ __ ] Denny's
okay cuz if now that part is in my
comedy special right and then we got
this call from him on the hotline and
this was a call that came in right here
here we go
hey do my wife and I were watching your
special on Netflix last week and we both
almost had heart attacks when he started
talking about shooting up a daze because
when I was 99 went
you know first shooting up a Denny's the
story I'd love to tell you
Wow that's the dark arts right there boy
and we're gonna get we're gonna call
them right now let's move our first live
call and we're gonna hear we're gonna
hear we're gonna hear the story so I'm
excited I hope you guys are I'm grateful
that we came this far because to me this
is a big deal and you're talking to a
man who if a camera doesn't work I'll
get some color pencils and take a sketch
pad with me
you know I'll stay old-fashioned if I
have to you know you know I'll send a
homing pigeon out there hell I'll send a
[ __ ] I'll send a nightingale you know
with a little bit of graffiti on his leg
you know I'm okay with going
old-fashioned so to be this high-tech
right now and be doing this man I'm I'm
keyed up
I'm hopped up boy this is a digital
cocaine right here here we go hey
brother it's Theo hey buddy how's it
going man it's good how are you good to
hear from you yeah well look it's good
to hear from you you know assuming that
obviously your your release date and we
you know we got your call on the hotline
and I appreciate you calling I
appreciate you listening to the podcast
always man
big fan big fan well thank you very much
yeah you said you and your wife were
checking out the Netflix and installed a
bit about Denny's and uh if you don't
mind we you just take us from there yeah
yeah we were we were watching the
Netflix special and got to that point
and man we just looked at each other and
almost fell over because it was it
brought me back in you know when I'll
just tell you from the beginning so you
were part of
you were part of shooting up at Denny's
is this yeah yeah yeah yeah I was that's
cool I mean it's unfortunate but it's uh
I mean it's I mean it's dark to be
laughing at this but this the dark arts
and sometimes the dark arts brings
people together you know sometimes it
brings people together you know and we
are together we are yeah we are and I'm
nervous and look I'm excited this is my
first call that we've ever had in on on
this past weekend so well I certainly
nervous about that geez man that I don't
think you could tell us a more
heartwarming story though you know
because sometimes people got to pop off
at a Denny's you know we've all wanted
to and so tell me tell me what happened
man okay well let me just start from the
beginning when I was uh when I was 14
years old I had a my sister who was like
a couple years older than I am she had a
boyfriend
mm-hmm who was he was in the military
and again she was 16 years old oh so
he's older much older Wow
I never really knew how old he was but
he was in the military and you know he
only hung around with her for about a
year or so but were they in lovely think
if you look back on it no no well she
might have you know she might have been
uh yeah I I have no idea right she but
but she might have been you never know
yeah so your sisters datin this fella
she's datin this fella I'm 14 years old
maybe 13 I'm not I'm not exactly sure
sapling out there and you young to me
you're probably coming into your own at
that age a little bit no I was I was
that was a long long way away before
before I was ever done in my own are you
still a novice you still out there
tadpole and you heavy poling out there
most certainly yeah I've been out there
man yeah I was a I was a late bloomer
for sure yeah and this guy I'll call
Rambo
because she to me at the time he he was
he was he was a badass he was Rambo he
was he didn't wear the eyeglass he bore
the eye black under his eyes and stuff
at dinner that kind of day no no I'd
like yeah I feel like because I'm
picturing a dude like you know elbow
crawling across your living room you
know to try and spend time with your
sister but you know he he made a sound
like that to me why right you know he
come to me he made himself out to be
this you know
just killer yeah so he was really looked
up to him it sounds like yeah I did I
really did I thought I thought he was
the best yeah then and then out of
nowhere he just disappears and you know
my life goes on and you know I'm sad for
a while but things go on and things
change but you know here comes 19 years
old Adams Adams 19 years old and I don't
remember how he came back into my life
but he did and it ended up hanging out
with me and my friends and the two that
the key figures in the story are myself
Rambo and my buddy too dark mark too
dark mark okay too dark mark and I'm
guessing he wasn't was he in the BP oil
spill we're talking about a brother a
brother he's certainly a brother
certainly a great fella and I can't you
know see I can't say too much of great
things about him he's an awesome day and
too dark you just mean he just has dark
dark skin dark dark skin you can't see
em can't fam ya see ya again oh yeah
real super black person you keep a
secret
you know yeah and I and that's so
because we're all on the spectrum
whether you some people are almost
see-through when you can see their veins
you can see their heartbeat a little bit
set on they'll eat lunch and you can
almost see it kind of going under the
skin a little bit yeah and then you have
the other end of the spectrum where
people are so dark you know they usually
end up being soccer players I feel like
in Britain
that's just that's my evaluation but yes
onward take us more yeah
Rambow new dark mark and myself we were
hanging out and we decide that we want
to go play pool
well they to decide that they want to go
play pool one night and you're tagged I
don't know yeah I don't necessarily want
to go but Rambo and intimidates me into
going yeah right I don't want to go
because I've already got the feeling he
just came back from Desert Storm oh yeah
then you generally not yeah yeah this is
both cold PTSD when people you didn't
even know what they were it was just
wild right and they came back yeah if
that person asked you to do something we
just came back from service you always
did it didn't matter you know right you
always done it and so I went you know
we're gonna play pool i regretting Lee
agree and we drive to we're getting
marks or to dark marks car and we go to
Rambo's house to pick up the pool cues
but you know when we get there and I
have no idea that when we get there that
they pick up the pool cues not only do
they pick up the pool cues but they also
pick up a couple of handguns boy couple
heaters huh yes nice bro amicus yeah a
couple of freaking hand rockets dude you
know what I'm saying
yeah they pick them up they didn't tell
me because I'm in the backseat yeah he
tells the backseat guy uh-hum but he
tells the backseat guys anything
no in a drive-by use of the backseat
guys the guy to set the look on his face
like what the [ __ ] going on exactly
okay so you guys cruise off you got the
pieces you're going to play pool right
we're driving down the street we drive
past Denny's and I see my girl who is a
friend but I'm saying that because my
wife is in the other room and I want to
make sure she knows that nothing ever
happened understood and my car is there
deniz and we decided to stop of course
you see your car someone's you're gonna
stop yeah cool I'm hungry we're gonna
hang out we're going to eat a little bit
we stop we pull over we stop and wait a
little bit we hang out talk and by this
point it's 2 or 3 o'clock in the morning
and we're done we decide we're gonna
leave pay our bill get up walk out get
in the car and we get in the car
of course again I'm in the backseat
right try driving off so you got that
dinner Y all hopped up on Denny's y'all
leaving I'm fat falling sleeping yeah
yeah I'm fat for sleeping they still
want to go play pool oh yeah we never go
play pool but we're pulling out before I
know it too dark mark and Rambo are
leaning out the car shooting the signs
and the windows and the glass with the
guns that they never told me that they
had pulled out right and so they just
start popping off at this Denny's they
start popping the Denny's off and just
lighten the place up Wow and you're
telling me that you didn't know a dude
named Rambo and too dark more I didn't
know that then we're gonna be doing it
right then at the same time I thought
they had done it out of their system in
the military Wow
well that's it you know they don't we
don't have enough date they should put
more Denny's out there in the desert you
know yeah so so then you guys take off
so now you're well no I'm on yelling
let's go let's go let's go
but you know one thing I didn't say
earlier was earlier in the day
Rambo had been wearing this stupid
leather fedora that looked like
something out of Indiana Jones not even
what not even worn and dusty or anything
just brand new off the shelf at Sears I
am and where is this what area of the
country's is in
this is Dallas Texas oh hell yeah boy
pop now our people are on it when
they're shooting like are people running
and scared or what's going on I don't
know I don't remember yeah I have no
idea yeah because I'm caught up in the
fact that these fools are shooting I you
know I'm 19 years old yeah I'm scared
shitless
are you excited now you said you're
scared I could get that 100% Israel
after they pull the guns in the car is
there is there a little bit of
excitement maybe there's a little bit of
yeah I'm a badass maybe a tiny bit of
that yeah yeah I could imagine this yeah
maybe a little bit not yeah I mean this
is this before that video again what's a
video game that everybody plays Grand
Theft Auto yeah this is before that this
is real-life Grand Theft Auto at Denny's
Wow man amazing man and so he's got this
stupid hat on and he's leaning out the
window at the same time driving both of
them the cars moving forward they're
shooting when wind catches the [ __ ]
hell right oh yeah when hates has wind
hate hats especially large brim hats Oh
it catches real it it causes a lift and
it raises the car up a little bit uh-huh
and raises his head up and off his head
and it flies off and he starts yelling
go back for the Hat go back for that and
I'm yelling no don't go back for the hat
go but don't go back for that
yes if anybody knows anything about
anything they know that at 2 or 3
o'clock in the morning at Denny's
there's police there yeah this is the
most French this is the most French
ending to a Rambo movie ever there's a
shooting and you go back for the most
homoerotic hat ever a fedora I fee for
the door there is nothing more that is
so free
bro so how does it end man tell us how
it is okay so it ends by well there's
still a little bit a little bit a little
bit less okay it okay
he's I'm saying don't go back he's
saying go back to dark mark stops the
car puts in a reverse goes back I
realized I have no choice but to get out
and get the [ __ ] hat I open the door
I see that how to reach my hand out pull
it up grab it pull it up bring it in
that and I sit back up only to see
police lights everywhere Wow and before
I knew it there was a boot and a shotgun
in the back of my head and neck I was on
the whole I was on the floor on the
ground and what were they saying were
they nice or not nice no no they were
not nice they were you know certainly
shouting expletives and get the [ __ ] on
the ground and you know taking advantage
of their their their positions in the
world
there's badge balls they had badge balls
huh oh yeah absolutely and were they
using were they now did you notice
because it sounds like you and Rambo or
white or Caucasian and that too dark
mark seems like he might have been a
little more urban was there any
favoritism there no where it seemed just
even across the board no because we
lived in you know we were we live in a
ghetto right you know and III know you
know yeah it it yeah this is everybody's
a piece of [ __ ] over there yeah
everybody's a piece of [ __ ] yeah so yeah
sorry was nothing danny's yeah anybody
don't like anybody get hurt no well you
know I never heard yeah I don't think so
yeah and the fucked-up thing about it
was my girlfriend was in there and these
whole still did it
dang dude that's so Ray Carruth bro that
sounds like that duh like that
god that's such a you shot up a Denny's
with your girlfriend in it man that's
love in some places that is true love
that's true man it's like if you let
something go and it comes back
to you that it's meant to be I think
that is a definition of that right okay
so I go to jail they arrest me and then
being in the military they're their
commanding officers they call them and
immediately they're snatched up out of
there
out of the jails in no time they spend
maybe an hour in jail right now of
course and I'm terrified in jail and
this is the I go straight downtown
Dallas and it is uncle Lou it's like
what a lot of it a lot of like you know
people that were like train robbers and
stuff like that type of people or thugs
thugs I mean nothing but thugs do you
have to watch anybody take a [ __ ] in
there like if you're in there is there
one toilet or what's that like yeah yeah
it was the stainless steel toilet
stainless steel toilet with what do you
know you're not afraid to use the
bathroom I don't think I shattered
pissed once yeah I would cough it up if
I had to there's no way for no for 24
hours I didn't [ __ ] or piss or eat or
anything oh I would cough all the [ __ ]
in my body right up out of my face
because there's no way that I would sit
down or turn my back on a group of
people with my penis in my hand and in a
place like that that is crazy
no so when you were sitting in there
what's going through your head just fear
uh fear I'm [ __ ] cold as [ __ ] cuz
they keep it you know 37 degrees in
there maybe and all the cold or it's in
there too
the cold hearts everybody's an [ __ ]
yeah everybody's got an attitude but
I'll tell you what I did meet this one
dude who had one leg and I'm not
[ __ ] you he had one leg and he had
been arrested for well he came home him
and his wife had come home and they had
locked themselves out of their house
uh-huh
so they begin to break into their house
because it was late and we're going to
go home and they were tired it's their
house it's their home they break into
the house and you know it's late
they're probably been drinking they get
in and they start you know doing the
nasty sanitary sex you know oh I didn't
know you were [ __ ] wiping boogers on
each other dude you know there's a lot
of a lot of different definitions of the
of a nasty out there we still hide we
used to try to hide sugar packets in
each other's ass dude and that was like
it was like wrestling if you could get
one of those pink saccharin packets into
somebody's ass you want you know try try
hiding a Hershey's kiss and somebody's
asked while you're sleeping next to them
come on boy I thought that's a girl off
yeah exactly take the foil off and tuck
it up in there and see what see how they
wake up in the morning take the foil oh
come on man you've changed yeah you've
changed
take the foil off okay so yeah dude gets
arrested or no the neighbors call on him
being too loud and they think somebody's
breaking into the house next door police
come and he's got one leg he's having
sex with his wife and he's arrested with
a bottle of KY in one hand and a dildo
in the other party and that's how he
shows up to the jail that's all I
remember really I don't remember
anything else except for that dude
that's that's uh that's silver we're in
Palm Springs bro that's that's San
Francisco silverware dude a dildo in a
bottle of KY son that's all that is
that's a cutlery set ah Wow well it's it
man it's just remarkable man you know I
appreciate you so much for calling and
now you have a you have a wife you said
I have a wife and three children three
girl was beautiful man you guys still
live there in Texas
yep that's awesome and I love Texas my
favorite state to perform in I can't
wait for you to come back down here yeah
let me know man we look what I'm not
gonna we're gonna ride separately to the
show but I'd love you I won't let you go
won't let you anywhere near my wife okay
that's fair oh I'm already worn her
I've already
order okay I'll hit you anywhere near a
gun if I've written one okay
amen I carry my own now these days these
are mine and legal that's what I'm
saying because here's the crazy part if
there's people that you as a child out
there as an adult you have to be
prepared you know exactly exactly that's
exactly I heard I got to protect my
girls from people like me
yeah that's it dude that's the exact I
don't have children yet but that's
exactly I'm sure what goes through a lot
of dads heads you know of course of
course Adam we appreciate it so much man
this is awesome it's been a great first
call this is like a milestone kind of
for the podcast and uh do you I hope I
came through for you you did 100%
there's a good practice just to talk to
somebody for the first time and and have
it be such a like a thing that you know
I just you know was talking about
something and you had actually lived it
out so oh yeah you have no you have no
idea how nervous I was man dude me to me
to 100% so we were both nervous we got
it done together man I appreciate you
beautiful buddy all right I will you
don't bless you and take care same here
and if you hear that I'm coming to town
has dropped me a text on the hotline and
I'll uh I'll get you guys some tickets -
be my guest for sure beautiful man thank
you all right happy New Year to you and
your family bro army you too take care
all right bye-bye
Wow and there you heard it right there
and you know what's why it would smiled
and thank you so much Adam for calling
in and what's what's even Wilder is on
my Facebook page some on my Facebook
page there is uh there is a there's the
clip of his Denny's and the Denny's bit
is just about I hated going to Denny's
it was an early comedy bit of mine it's
one that I I didn't do on the road last
year but I still love it I just haven't
done it in a long time and you know I
played a little bit for you a second ago
but some somebody posted on my Facebook
page my dad actually got shot to death
at a Denny's because somebody ran him
with guns and shot it up and I'm reading
this and I'm like holy [ __ ] man this is
horrible he goes but I still
love this comedy bit that's what he said
and then he posted a link to thee to the
news story that happened when I believe
his father got killed out of Denny so
r.i.p to his father you know this is
kind of like kind of cornered myself
into a weird spot here but but you know
you just never know you know here you
know here's something tragedy that
happened to that man that happened to
that boy's father but then years later
he you know he sees it online and is
able to laugh a little bit so I know
that's not the way that some people want
to laugh but I'm glad that it worked out
that way for that young man
I'm glad Adam didn't go to jail because
he gots a beautiful family now and
that's just a word out there that we can
all cover from you know something heavy
something hit you you can recover you
know three years ago my brother's house
burned down they got hit by lightning
you know they got hit by dang lightning
and you can do a lot of stuff in your
life you can learn to read you can learn
to swim you can learn to dance you can
graduate college you can graduate high
school you can get a GED none of that
you can own a biz none of that shit's
you can't stop getting hit by lightning
sometimes life gonna throw you that
those curve lightnings you know and you
just you got to bounce back whatever it
is and this man Adam that called in shot
up a dang dinh Easy's you know and now
he's back he's back he has a family and
he's living life and we appreciate him
being the first caller on this past
weekend for this past Thursday episode
oh man he it was a slow call though at
some points I'm like damn am I still
paying attention to this story but maybe
I wasn't asking some of the right
questions you know we learn as we go we
learn as we go we want to thank our
charter sponsor gray block pizza you
know cuz MCATs is out there doing it
right we got a couple of calls that came
in we had a young lady that called who
is still a virgin Danielle the 25 year
old virgin and you know sometimes she's
worried does that affect her you know
ability to have
you know how we'll guys look at it we
got some calls about that because that
thing can get a little ripe
you know that thing can get a little bit
right you know first it's a peach and
then after a couple years it's more of
an apricot and then you just running
around with there just a bag of raisins
between your legs so sometimes you have
to figure that out but we're
appreciating alling in Danielle we're
gonna get to that advice here in just a
second a fresh new year has begun and if
you're setting new goals for your
business it's extremely difficult to
reach them goals without the right
people on your team where would Michael
Jordan be without the other players he
played with well zip recruiter comm has
transformed how you go about finding the
other members of your team zip recruiter
posts your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards with just one click
so imagine just making a click boom
suddenly you got people around that want
to work for you knock knock who's there
potential employees zip recruiter
actively looks for the most qualified
candidates and invites them to apply no
wonder 80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day can you
believe the internet will bring you
somebody worthwhile finally after all
these being on tinder and all of this
it's finally nice to be in a place where
I'm gonna find somebody decent that's
right and our listeners can post on zip
recruiter for free that's right for free
right now just go to zip recruiter
dot-com slash tpw that's zip recruiter
dot-com slash tpw if you put someone
another side you're gonna get you know
another site type of person go get the
best and you don't have to do the
looking let sip recruiter com look for
you so that's it we got the dinners we
got the first call out of the way that's
exciting in the future if you need help
with something if you're struggling you
know it could be with anything smoking
buying a home drugs you know you got a
ashy skin menthol peanut butter could be
anything whatever your issue is if you
need basic life suggestions it's
something that I can help with hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three we had some great
calls that come in and one of those was
Danielle the Virgin from last week and
I'm sorry to just call you that Danielle
if you're listening this week on
Thursday today that they're probably
makes you feel a little bit awkward you
know cousin others more a lot more to
you than just that you know just that
than just that locked up little garage
you know just then just that locked up
little sweat Locker you know I know
there's more I know there's a lot more
to you but what you called about was
that huh you know what you called about
was that spicy little vCard
and that's what we want to talk about so
some some people called him with advice
for you she's 25 she wanted to know if
it affects it how way the way that men
look at her think about her or any
suggestions here we go this is rock yeah
this is Rob from Massachusetts calling
in with my two cents on your caller who
is a virgin I call them she's a couple
of options here one of them is you know
she's got to go out there and put
herself out there I remember a time when
I was in college with all my friends
I was the bars drinking I would love you
know someone walked up to me and said
hey let's go do this I'm a virgin
it wouldn't have thought twice that's
true that sound like a drink special
right there I mean you could let me tell
you this if you set up a deal with a
local bar Danielle and just to pick a
man and you I'm not saying to sell your
body or anything like that I'm not
trying to be you know degrading to you
I'm just piggybacking off a Rob's idea
because Rob obviously has issues that
he's offering this up I'm joking Rob but
um but that's the fact that yeah if you
set up with a with a bar said hey look
I'm a virgin let's have meet a virgin
night who and you took 50% of the door
now we're talking you're making $1,500 a
weekend and you still have your
virginity pending upon how the night
goes and what you're into let's hear
more Rob
I think that maybe she's overestimating
people's apprehension to that you know
if you drink some people are gonna do
what they're looking to do when they go
to bars if she's she's willing to go out
to those types of settings other option
if she's you know not looking for the
one-night-stand type thing is put
yourself out there in a relationship and
this you connected with somebody and you
end up sharing with them that you're a
virgin
they should be happy for you they should
be happy to share that experience with
you and if they're not and they think
that it's off-putting then maybe you
shouldn't be with that person there you
go
that's two other beautiful little slices
of information cake they're from Rob so
you know Phil you're sweet tongue up
with that with that frickin pastry right
there boy Rob dropping them sweet
pastries in Anna Danielle's ear holes
because that's the only thing you can
see only holes you can fill on her right
now boom boom bad joke but that's it
Danielle was like you know you could you
know make it a promotional type of thing
at a bar if you're trying to make it
exciting you could you know if it's
religious base then you know just keep
following your heart there you know when
talked to you know um you know someone
you trust in the religious realm if you
need that or talk to other friends who
have the same beliefs in the same level
of beliefs that you do the same
practices that you do and I'm sure they
can give you guidance if you I mean you
said it's it's not because you haven't
wanted to but because men hadn't really
you know tried to get that from you
hadn't trying to get that dug dug out of
you you know hadn't trying to freaking
hunt down that little you know that that
uh that slick mouth lobster trap you
know and if that's the case then ya
might just be meeting the right guy you
know you could track somebody down and
if you really wanted to you could tell
them that you're ready to serve that
thing up and somebody would but it can
be dangerous to a man it can be
nerve-racking you know maybe you could
make a special night out of it invite a
guy over to a nice hotel room do it your
way you know that Burger King that
Burger King for Janet ah but young man
will do anything that was a good point
rob Mae young men will do anything I
mean I remember I said go party
some people in every night I would pee
all over this guy has got Christopher
he's in prison now and his day we would
take his dad's car out and his dad had
sunglasses in the back and I would
urinate all it hit they were samples his
dad sold sunglasses to people around you
know around the region you know he was
in that regional optical game and I
would uh you know I'd take a couple hits
of weed and I would urinate all over the
glasses in the back of this guy's van I
mean and we go to parties I wouldn't
even go to it go to the party I would
literally stay in the van drinking
alcohol and peeing on these boxes of
glasses and the only reason I would do
it was because the rest of the week I
wanted to be at school or whatever and
picture in my mind a man trying to sell
just PP glasses to people you know just
trying to sell pissed specs to people
out there people trying to trying them
on
you know them getting a little bit stuck
to people's hair and stuff like that
like that's the dark arts was in me you
know that's the dark arts that affected
my ability to think and and you know and
it was making me behave that way
and that's what I wanted to do though so
instead of enjoying the party in the
present moment I would choose to stay in
a van and urinate on um on sale samples
just because of the joy it would bring
me the rest of the week picture in
people trying on oakley's you know that
smell a little bit too strong of a
vitamin b12 you know but anyhow that
just goes say young men will do anything
here's another call from Zak for you
Danielle here we go man Zak calling from
Omaha Nebraska I wanted to call and give
my opinion - sweet sweet Danielle who
you put on there the 25 year old virgin
she left not a lot of information to
what I would say is that if she's gonna
lose her virginity to a guy that's like
25 you know her age or older there's
probably gonna be some consideration
there at least at first and then let you
said though these guys are going to be
thinking about this it's gonna be
turning them on they're gonna want to be
that first ride the first one to dig her
out dude yeah bro I hear you dude you're
making me fricking feel squirrely my
second digger out right there but we'll
keep listening I mean I don't mean to
sound you know crude or
or whatever toward her you know you
definitely do I mean you sound like a
dank gravedigger do dig her out I mean
dang man
Sheena coughing hole bruh you know I'm
just giving you a hard time let's hear
more but it was a little bit crude
onward she's a virgin I just I don't
know if she's not full of [ __ ] then then
I think that she should worry at all
there you go
I mean that's the thing there's been a
billion virginity's in the world people
have gotten rid of them in different
places and you know I mean I know it's
important to you you know it's not gonna
probably change the shape of the
universe too much but it will be
something you'll remember you know I
mean I remember you know mod lost my
virginity behind a bowling alley you
know when people were throwing rocks at
me the whole time I was trying to have
sex and that's very you know it's a very
Middle Eastern if you will and it's hard
to keep an erection up with that kind of
stuff going on and so you know we all
have a memory we all have something
happens I was in Charleston South
Carolina and I made love to some gal and
it was her first time you know and I
still I still think about sometime about
her you know she had you know she was a
pretty girl she had curly hair sometime
I still think about her you know I'm
wondering where she's at if she ever
thinks about you know that moment in
time you know that I was the first
experience and probably even that good
either but that's a thing if there's
dudes that are touted that aren't good
at sex this is a great opportunity for
them all right let's move along here we
go this was a Matt called in on 12 21 he
had a food addiction we gave some you
know some suggestions to him a last
episode and and then he called back this
was a Matt's call that just came in on
the hotline here we go hey and you know
I listen back to that Matt and I want to
apologize for calling you fat man
it just I was just trying to make a
point that we all have some name you
know we all have you know blind Ryan you
know or deaf Jeff if you're deaf and if
your name is Jeff and if you're even
saying that to Jeff he
and care you know or you know bent Clint
you know if somebody that has scoliosis
and their name is Clint we actually had
a boy named Clint in our class and
people called him MA
Clint Taurus you know and so everybody
has something with their name so I just
that was the correlation I was trying to
make I was actually trying to relate to
you I think I did it in a bad way by
calling calling you fat met here we go
called Lucy ass [ __ ] but you know
sometimes you do need to hear that so
yeah yeah I'm sorry about that part I
you know I'm just you know the new year
I was feeling fired up and you know some
of the calls I mean you know have a
system now that's helping put these
through so I hear them for the first
time and I thought that that was out of
line but then sometimes we got to hear
that [ __ ] sometimes we don't wanna hear
the truth out here in the world and and
you know and I know it's not my job to
decide what the truth is for you but I
was just giving you the different
options that came in let's hear more
Matt playing water do now that plain
water you set yourself up there by
saying you didn't like plain water
do you gotta have water because Mother
Earth is 98% water dude so you can't be
associated with something that you're
not willing to take into yourself so you
need to get out there and get that h2o
and your brother more I agree don't
sound fat at all dude you sound trim you
know and we all have something dude you
know I got a you know of the base of the
foundation the hip structure of a Down
Syndrome child that's not bad and make
them bad people and doesn make me a bad
person you know you might be bigger now
and you might be smaller later you know
I was real skinny growing up and
everybody called me Mexican all the time
because I had tan skin cuz he bore
idiots let's hear more I appreciated
checking on a few months and they saw
everything's going you know plain water
and some hungry great
there we go that's plain water met baby
that's plain water Matt right
and look man I'd love it if you want to
send a picture in you can text it into
the hotline number nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three Matt and
yeah we'll check in with you man
we'll check I'm trying to get back into
some physical fitness myself so you
saying that right there inspires me to
say look if if I can sit here and put on
a hotline that some guy you know talking
about some man that needs to lose weight
at least that I can do is to get out
there and go for a run for myself and
help my own veins and arteries feel a
little bit better so I wish you well and
uh and we'll check back in with you man
all right let's keep the calls moving
here we got um we got another couple of
calls that came in but first I want to
read this to you guys you know a fresh
new year has begun and if you're setting
new goals for your business it's
extremely difficult to reach them
without the right people on your team
well zip recruiter has transformed how
you go about finding those people that's
the truth if you're need a great talent
for your business but you're short on
time you don't have to get lost in a
huge stack of resumes to find your
perfect hire that stack of resumes is
waiting out there electronically and you
just need smarter tools to reach them
those tools zip recruiter has zip
recruiter post your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards with just
one click so if you're applying for a
job or you're looking for a hire go to
zip recruiter zip recruiters com unlike
other hiring sites it doesn't depend on
the right candidates finding you it
finds them no wonder 80% of employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day so if you need your yard raked you
need your taxes done you need your
somebody to make love to your wife that
might be a stretch but I bet if you ask
nicely
zip recruiter has not only people who
can do that do your position literally
but people who can do the position the
best go to zip recruiter dot-com slash
tpw that's right
zip recruiter comp zip recruiter com /t
P W you can post jobs for free that's
for free so try it out that's all you're
gonna do you're gonna go to zip
recruiter calm and post jobs for free
zip recruiter comm /t PW and post jobs
for free all right we got a call right
here
I want to crack into this and here we go
you know looks good the this is a
Jackson feather you know North Maggie
Jackson thanks for calling man from
North Carolina I'm calling because uh I
got right now on the 29th of December I
have five minutes sober and I mean I'm
being getting hot since I was right
I mean Harlem pills I started smoking at
11 like I started getting higher 14 hey
man congratulations on five months if
that was December 29th and you are
tomorrow or in two days you'll be you'll
be at five months in a week
so congratulations meadow no that's a
real battle onward started using her
needle 17 I lost my best friend and I
got my first first taste of real
sobriety in there longer than a week or
so this past year and like I said I'll
be five months in the 29th man that's
awesome man man that scares me just to
hear you say that using a needle that's
scary bro
you know I can't you know I never had
that experience so I don't know what
that's like but I know what it's like to
want to to do things to yourself that
are harmful but they feel good you know
I know what that's like I know what it's
like to harm yourself but it feels good
to make yourself feel at all you know
and I don't know if that makes a hundred
percent of sense but in my mind and my
heart it does that I know what it's like
to you know to do bad things to yourself
yeah just to be in that hole where the
way that you you know because you're in
a world for me anyway you know I just
didn't care about myself
enough to do good things to myself
because I just somewhere inside of me
felt like I didn't deserve those things
so but yeah I mean that scares me when I
see that I mean there's you know when I
see those intervention shows and I see
people that's a pod just can't watch
that stuff because of that but I
appreciate being brave enough to tell us
about that
homeward yeah basically man uh I don't
know life just gives more in this book
it's like I don't know what to do now
like drugs always so much fun Tom and I
know going back to the mango Misha fun
at all I'm not as funny easy to fall
into this hole I found this girl I know
they say not to get in a relationship
but I think I'm in love I don't know if
I'm telling the boys of that I don't
know but the thing is she's she
long-distance man and I'm crazy over and
it's hard to make it work living across
the country right now but I mean I'd
rather have her than any girl that I
could have here but it's like I have a
hard time trusting and I'm real jealous
and real needy and it's just I don't
know if there's control of me I don't
know if it's but part of my addiction I
don't know I don't know man it's so
funny when you say I don't know man you
sound like me
you sound like me sometimes just it's
almost like hearing myself in certain
relationships and certain conversations
I've been in with with people you know
especially with girls look man I'm proud
of you you know I think 12-step programs
I don't care if you don't have anything
going on your life we can all always
find ways to make our life healthier and
and and it's amazing man it's amazing
what can happen in there now that long
distance dude I'll tell you this you
know even in my past year I felt like I
you know met a girl and at times put
that in front of getting a a good
foundation in a my sobriety and stuff
like that so you know I used that term
loosely my sobriety I mean everybody has
their own walk with it you know I don't
know if I'll always be this way you know
I don't know but for now I just know
that I didn't really I didn't lay the
groundwork as well as I should have and
so then when relationships get tough I
don't have a foundation to fall back on
so that's scary so I would it's okay I
feel like if you want to put a girl up
with your you know with the work you're
doing but you got to do that work man
you know and I'm and I'm saying that
because I need to hear it because you
know I've been in this thing a year and
a half and I'm still you know having
gone all the way through the steps so
you know there's just just be careful
you know be careful because it seem like
you know you can still be learning how
to live and you don't have all the tools
and then you take on a responsibility
like love and that can be a big
responsibility for somebody that uh you
know that doesn't you know have arms yet
you know so keep your head up man
I love you bro you know I'm proud of you
you calling me hearing that from you
it made me feel you know made me feel
alive which is crazy because that's
probably something that drugs used to do
for you but now it's like the drug that
I think a lot of these programs get you
hooked on is just the react the
heaviness the heaviness of other
people's life's and the realities of
other people's lives and uh anyhow happy
to be happy to be on board with you but
happy to be have you on the show and and
thank you very much for calling what
else we got a couple of other things
that caught that happened but I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna shut it down for
today guys it's been a good episode I
feel like we'll be back on Monday what
else we got the dates we let all those
out gray block pizza as always we just
they had somebody hit up gray block and
in comments on there we had somebody hit
up gray blocking comments on their Yelp
page that they heard about him here and
that was awesome and I mean you feel
really really cool they got that salad
pizza brother they got it all but that's
it man well we'll catch you guys next
time
Matt you know I appreciate your call
Zach thank you for calling in for the
advice Rob all that advice for Danielle
that Denny's a shoot-'em-up bang bang
boy that pop pop breakfast dude that
syrup has a fug in a sulfur e aftertaste
doesn't it because that's that gunplay
that's that gunplay out in the lot
booboo so you stay active man you stay
active that's what we doing out here
that's what we doing out here in in this
world thank you guys for being a part of
this past weekend see you on Monday
that's Jesse Lucero taking us out Thank
You Cory for being here today to guide
us Thank You patreon taking us that next
level here we got some nice cameras are
looking clean we got the new hotline
where we're gonna be able to talk to
people and what can happen what can
happen anything can happen
you'll be working together out here in
this new year also if you got a new
year's resolution that you've been
keeping on this heavy with you that's a
real one some real [ __ ] have let us know
it's a Jessie Lucero right there thank
you for that hit Jesse we'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
be good to yourselves you probably
deserved